hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today
i will be talking about the attack on
titan anime going nuclear with the
introduction of
armin's colossal titan form
i will also break down the survey course
plans to attack marlei
plants that armin was largely
responsible for and of course i will
talk about levi versus the beast titan
part 2.
the aaron vs the warhammer titan end
game and so much more so let's get into
it
if you enjoy our attack on titan videos
and you want us to keep it going do me a
favor and hit that like button
it really does help and if you're new to
anime pro or maybe you just haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
finally this video is made possible by
our anime uproar
patrons i will talk more about patreon
at the end of the video but now
let's jump into the action through the
conversation between willie tiber and
general
theo mcgath we learned that willie and
mcgath were pretty much expecting aaron
to attack them in liberio
during the festival they had been aware
for a while that spies had infiltrated
the marlene army
but they didn't know the identities of
the infiltrators so they had to find a
way to smoke them out
willy believed that the festival was the
perfect way to do it
although he recognized that if the
attack does indeed happen
willie himself would likely be
forfeiting his own life
however he was willing to make that
sacrifice in order to unite
the world against their common enemy
aaron jaeger
will he believe that if he the most
respected eldian in the world
lost his life at the hands of aaron then
the aldians on the continent would
finally gain
sympathy from the rest of the world and
aaron and his so-called
island devils would become everyone's
real
enemy so because mcgath and willy knew
that an attack was possible
they made preparations willy served as
the bait for aaron
but he wasn't even the real warhammer
titan shifter he just wanted aaron to
believe
that he was meanwhile the marland
military had secretly prepared
anti-titan artillery to take aaron down
once he showed up
in his titan form and beyond that the
marland military always knew
that they have superior numbers the
paradise forces don't have enough
soldiers or enough weapons to fight the
marlin army
head on so mcgath made sure that over 30
thousand marlan troops would be
in the vicinity of liberio at the time
of the festival and so
as soon as aaron's attack began mcgath
called in
those 30 000 reinforcements and told
them to converge on liberio
in order to seal all the islanders in
and not let him escape
in the mind of the marlins yes they just
suffered some serious losses because of
aaron's attack
but at least now they've got aaron
trapped and with their superior numbers
they will be able to retake the founding
titan once and for all
and if they can make that happen then
all of the sacrifices they've just made
will have been worth it except they
didn't count on attack on titan's very
own fallout boy
armin arlert back when bertolt was using
the colossal titan power on paradise
we learned that the user of the colossal
titan shifter can control how explosive
his titan transformation will become
he can make it fairly harmless if he
wants to
but he can also create a giant explosion
when transforming an explosion that
causes
mass destruction and leaves behind a
huge mushroom cloud
similar to a nuclear explosion so when
the marland reinforcements began
converging on the port and as they
prepared to hoist their trap upon
aaron armin manages to annihilate their
entire fleet by sneaking up on them on a
small fishing boat and then
detonating his massive colossal titan
transformation
with most of their reinforcements
destroyed in an instant
the marland forces suddenly don't look
nearly as strong as they did
just moments ago and the tables quickly
turn in favor of the survey core
back in the barrio peak and porco are
using their titans to fight off the
survey corps soldiers
but using their incredible agility and
their thunderspears
sasha jean and the other survey corps
members are able to disarm and defeat
pique's cartman titan in fact it looks
as if pique is about to get killed by
jean but falco intervenes he puts
himself in between
jean and his target and he begs jon to
spare
pique's life seeing a young child in his
way
jean hesitates for just a moment but
that moment is enough to mess with
jean's aim and save peak from a fatal
injury
although not fatally injured pique is
still injured
and due to her titan's slower
regeneration this
injury takes her off the battlefield for
the foreseeable future
now we've already seen jean going out of
his way to avoid civilian casualties
during the attack on liberio and we even
saw him
arguing with flock about the need to be
more careful to avoid
harm to civilians so it makes perfect
sense that jon would hesitate at the
sight of falco who is
after all just a kid but jean's
compassion may come back to haunt him
because
pique is after all an enemy soldier
and not just any soldier but a titan
shifter
meanwhile armin's colossal titan form is
finally revealed
in all its glory and it is absolutely
epic armin's massive titan has all the
basic
features of a colossal titan but it also
has its own distinct appearance that
makes it different from bertolt's titan
the differences are most visible in the
titan's face
and man those eyes are both creepy
and awesome at the same time as armin
emerges from his titan
he says that this must have been the
same sight that bertolt saw when he
breached the walls and attacked paradise
bertolt also had a bird's-eye view of
all the death and destruction that his
attack had caused to all the
ordinary people on the ground and this
single line reminds us that
armin and the survey corps didn't start
this
war they were attacked first and they
were about to be attacked
yet again after all declaring war on
paradise was the whole point of this
year's festival
in liberio that is why the paradise
forces had to act
even though their actions were bound to
cause great suffering to the people of
liberia
armin is then picked up by an airship
which is being driven by oyan kunpong
and
hanji oyankonpon is a man whose country
was oppressed by marlei
and so he defected to paradise so that
he could fight against marley
and for the freedom of his homeland this
plan to use an airship to evacuate the
survey corps members
after the attack on the barrio was
concocted by the strategic mastermind
armin himself and this demonstrates just
how quickly the forces on parodies are
adapting to modern technology and
learning how to use it
just four years ago the islanders didn't
even know what an airship
was and now they are piloting an airship
in a major military offensive
from this point on things quickly go
from bad to worse for the marlin forces
inside liberio the one and only levi
takes down
zeke's beast titan and after realizing
that the only things that can damage
lara tiber's protective crystal are the
jaw titans jaws and claws
aaron ends up using the jaw titan as a
nutcracker to crack the crystal open
and consume lara's spinal fluid which of
course
allows aaron to take the warhammer titan
power
for himself by the way the anime
revealed that willie tiber's sister and
the holder of the warhammer titan's
first name
is lara in the manga we never actually
learned her first
name after consuming the warhammer titan
aaron is about to consume the jaw titan
as well
but luckily for porco reiner finally
manages to pull himself together and he
saves porco's life
in the nick of time but despite the
sudden reappearance of reiner's armored
titan
the marlan forces have been decimated
zeke
is down peak is down porco is down
the warhammer titan has been stolen by
aaron the reinforcements have been
annihilated
and the survey corps are about to make
their escape on an airship
as a result of some truly incredible
planning and some very good luck
aaron and the survey corps managed to
infiltrate liberio
steal the warhammer titan and destroy a
huge chunk of marley's military despite
being vastly outnumbered by the marlan
forces
and don't even get me started on how big
of an advantage the marlians have when
it comes to modern technology
including advanced weapons technology
but despite the fact that the attack on
the burial was definitely a strategic
success
we have to acknowledge that the
islanders did suffer casualties
they definitely lost some good soldiers
during this attack
and yet from a strategic perspective the
attack on the burial was a resounding
victory for the forces from parodies
with all of that said though this attack
on liberio is definitely going to
further encourage marlei and the other
nations to attack parodies
as soon as possible aaron had judged
that the invasion of paradise was
inevitable
so at least the attack on the barrio has
bought the islanders
some time however there is no doubt that
what happened in liberio
including the killing of world leaders
from other countries by
aaron and the survey corps is going to
make it even easier for marley to
convince the other nations that paradise
is a threat which must be neutralized
as soon as possible to be honest all-out
war
was always likely but now it is
practically
inevitable let me know what you guys
think what did you think about the anime
introduction
of armin's colossal titan and how strong
do you think
armin's titan is i think that armin's
titan has a lot of potential
especially when we take into
consideration armin's own
intelligence so i actually think that
armin's titan is stronger than bertolt's
colossal titan
also what did you think about the plan
to attack liberio
was it worth the price if you were aaron
would you have done everything the same
way as he did or would you have done
some things differently let me know down
below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more attack on titan content
right here on the channel
please leave that like to let me know it
really does help
and if you are new to anime pro or maybe
you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos even if
you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma a
disciple of lord twigo
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans
including ingrata the world acquired
respect
pate hepha rathee and yx emperor otaku
spidey life chanel big buddhist and
tungsten tarkis
finally thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews anatoly kazatsky
joe stanton barry gucci jessica kayla
font rothlin deora alicia octor
bonnie parks you know comey and water
the red-haired raymond
florian joanne garcia jack watches anime
fat boy games
deadly saint matthew cruz anthony
schreiber hi jinx and mr waffles 247.
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you